castle point and rochford health and
well-being strategy reset
mental health workshop from the 9th
september 2020
facilitated by sam ball who is from the
ccg
mental health commissioning team
three key questions to pull out from a
clinical commissioning perspective the
ccg is geographically aligned to
southend castle point and rockford
there are three things that would be
really valuable to pull out to help
enrich the mental health part of the
strategy
one what is the character of castle
point and rochford
two who are the key players who are
doing things that are making a
difference around mental health
that people are working in mental health
would need to know
for example the way volunteers were
mobilized during the covert 19 pandemic
this tells us something about the
community fabric these things are assets
that help people stay well and prevent
them becoming mentally ill in the first
place
three who are the unheard groups who out
there is not okay despite on
average castle point of rockford being
socioeconomically okay
and health opportunity wise being
relatively okay
mental health strategic drivers the nhs
long-term plan speaks about thresholds
to access secondary care and mental
health services
getting higher and higher this is owing
to services being organized in silos
driven by a diagnosis rather than need
and because of demand outstripping
resource
the long-term plan talks about how we
can change that and create more capacity
with investment to transform mental
health services
integration this is freeway between
health and social care but also between
mental health and physical health
primary care networks and social
prescribing link workers
these are our locality delivery
framework around which to hang services
community voluntary sector there are
huge opportunities as we transform
mental health services
to have a more enhanced role for the
community and voluntary sector
there are also local priorities these
are explained on the next slide
local priorities for a health and social
care lens
reflect those nationally there are high
thresholds for secondary care and siloed
pathways
for example in castle point and rochford
for every five referrals a gp will make
to a secondary mental health care
only four will end up being offered a
secondary mental health service
[ __ ] explained that this speaks to a
number of things really high thresholds
lack of capacity it being difficult for
gps to know where to place people
which means wasted time for primary and
secondary care practitioners
and a poor service user experience
large numbers of people managed in
primary care
the effects of kovin 19 and anticipated
surge
plans to address these integrated
primary community care placing senior
mental health practitioners
in each pcn in south east essex to
support those who don't meet eligibility
criteria
for improved access to psychological
therapies
also known as iapt or the threshold for
secondary health services
sambal commented on this saying we are
placing nine senior mental health
practitioners
one in each primary care network in
southeast essex
to meet the needs of people who fall
between iap and secondary care
redesigning provisions so that is more
integrated with primary care so that it
is more
needs-led and holistic an enhanced
therapeutic offer in the recovery
college
and wellbeing hubs creation of more
coherent preventative offers to support
patient flow
by allowing people to step down from
secondary care and create capacity
as well as changing the way services
look
other determinants to consider are
economic
lifestyle activity and family and social
what else do we need to consider what's
the 2019 jsna profiles tell us
from the 2019 joint strategic needs
assessment for castle point and rockford
we know that carlson point and rochford
ctg has the third highest prevalence
at 12.47 of depression and anxiety
in people over 18 compared across that
of the other
ccgs in essex this is similar to the
prevalence across
essex at 12.49 and lower than that
across england at 13.74 percent
21 of residents aged 16 to 65 plus
reported feeling
isolated from others this was the lowest
percentage compared to that of the other
districts in essex
and lower compared to ethics as a whole
at 25.5 percent
sam ball said that what this really
tells us is that castle point and
rockford
does not particularly stand out we are
not a particular outlier according to
the statistics
but that doesn't mean it isn't a problem
for individuals
approximately 0.6 percent of the
population of rochford
and 0.7 of the population of castle
point have a severe mental health
condition
such as schizophrenia bipolar affective
disorder
psychotic depression or another
psychotic illness
as recorded on general practice disease
registers
in 2017 to 18. this is below the essex
average at 0.8
an england average of 0.94
the estimated prevalence of any mental
health disorder in children and young
people aged 5 to 16 years
is 8.89 in castle point and 8.24 in
rochford
both are below the england value at 9.23
the castle point is higher than the
average prevalence across essex as a
whole
at 8.71
improved access to psychological
therapies also known as iapt
therapy for you is the nhs commission's
psychological therapy service
used to treat common mental health
conditions like depression
and anxiety disorders in south essex
therapy for use is roughly 5 000 to 6
000 people a year alone in castle point
and rockford
and more than 50 of those recovered from
their depression or anxiety
covered 19 has had a significant impact
on the number of people being referred
to iact in the last six months
in quarter one of this year april may
and june referrals to iaps fell well
below the target numbers
but has surged back up already beyond
the planned levels
sample explained that iapt is a busy
effective and well organized service
around quarter one of this year people
stopped coming to the services
they stopped seeking help for mental
health problems but it has surged back
up already
age and gender comparisons men are
underrepresented in iact
women fire outweigh men seeking help in
terms of psychological
therapy people over the age of 65 are
also underrepresented in iat
sambal explained that when we think
about early intervention and prevention
and the well-being of the population we
need to consider these facts
and how we make it okay for men and
older people to reach out for help
sometimes it can be generational that
people aren't comfortable having that
kind of conversation
we need to address this and reduce that
stigma
questions to consider these are the
questions we need to consider
one what does this data tell us two what
do you think
are the key priorities free how should
we be addressing them
let's also revert to the other three
questions mentioned at the beginning
one what is the character of castle
point and rochford
two who are the key players doing key
things that will help with mental health
and well-being
three who are the unheard groups and
individuals
who might not show on the statistics
because generally
in castle point and rockford things are
okay
phe prevention concordat this is a
national movement focusing on the
promotion of good mental health and
prevention of
mental health issues at a local level it
aims to facilitate local action
creating resilient communities by taking
a prevention-focused approach
our health and well-being board has
developed a series of shared commitments
focusing on cross-section action
over five key areas of work to become a
signatory
our commitment plan will be submitted to
public health england when the next
submission waves open late this year
this date is to be confirmed sam ball
commented saying
this is a commitment for everyone to
pull together and is a key part of the
health and wellbeing strategy
for caster point of rockford it speaks
to the opportunity to be more
preventative
and think about those community assets
and key players
comments from the discussion matt king
said the investment at the moment is in
primary care and mental health
and we at trustlinks are just about to
pilot a support worker role
based with the mental health nurse in
the canva pcn
this will be a voluntary sector support
worker who will provide a bridge through
to the voluntary community sector
services
and also provides some targeted
interventions for those who are
struggling to access services
perhaps aren't at the levels whose need
secondary mental health services
nick chard said looking at the current
strategy it only talks about the severe
mental health disorders
we talk about more demand than resource
available and prevention
that high level mental health is only
the tip of the iceberg
we need to make sure we include
preventative love of tears i.e community
therapy and statutory iaps services
which prevent people reaching that high
level mental health issue in the first
place
candice mcpherson said i do feel that
the early intervention and prevention
element is missing in the current
strategy
it is quite high level but what about
everything else
sam ball said building a prevention
pathway is an explicit
objective and pulling out the role of
the voluntary sector and having a
clearer bigger role for the voluntary
sector
is an explicit plan the feedback is that
we need to reflect that in the health
and wellbeing strategy
sambal also said regarding the point
about social isolation
is there a specific need for a
population because of how rural it is
are there people of transitional age who
are in danger of missing out on services
because of where they live
matt king responded to this saying with
kovid we've all gone digital
so people are accessing more if they are
digitally literate
but there is digital isolation too if
people don't have access to the internet
or aren't very good with technology
transport to access services
is also an issue particularly in
rochefort districts like great wakering
and for some south end becomes your main
center
because of the geography and where the
town is the issue with canby is the
issue of access off the island to access
services and also greater levels of
deprivation
and intergenerational deprivation on
canva we also need to mention young
people's mental health
even in affluent areas is a real issue
school pressure is placed on children to
perform and achieve
self-harming anorexia and anxiety is
probably a ticking time ball
nick chard said the children with
anxiety now are the mental health
patients of the future so we need to
make sure they are properly spotted now
to prevent
that future need candy's mcpherson said
my role is specifically more focused on
early years and young people
and i do find that i have to really push
that best start in life element
of the health and well-being strategy so
i think that is something to consider
counselor johnson said the problem with
the strategy is how deep do we
go in a document that makes it still
readable and something that
someone can pick up and understand my
fear is that if we start delving into
something too deep
then this becomes uninteresting for the
people who need this
and need to understand what is out there
for them the key themes from this
conversation are
isolation be that social rural or
digital
the role of the voluntary sector greater
emphasis on early years
and children and young people's mental
health
next steps to meet before the next board
meeting to continue discussion and
develop the narrative around this
priority
for our new strategy is there other
intelligence you can share to inform and
provide more insight
who needs to be involved and how what
other actions would you consider
necessary to help drive forward our
prevention
concordat commitment plan